i went to a knife fight without a knife  and i ended up looking like this and  they put holes in me  how how close were you to death dead  deal came they got me to the hospital i  was i'd bled out how many times did they  stab you i i  i'll leave that for my memoirs those  little beautiful details  for your memoirs  but you had no idea that these they just  attacked you no i i i yeah yeah i can't  mouth in them no they they told me they  [ __ ] up my brother  we've done your brother was the comment  and that in glasgow means he's done he's  he's over and i lost my [ __ ]  and i slapped some [ __ ] and i said  i'll take all you guys outside and i  went outside like  and i waited for him like a [ __ ]  idiot and i knew they they were sold out  but anyway they came out those fire eggs  and i went  and then  buy your spy yourself by myself with my  trusty heineken bottle  which was not very handy jesus christ  stop stop stop